This book was one of the most stolen
books from public libraries ever. And if
you want to grab it today, it's a $125.
There's a line right here that was
penned over 60 years ago. It says, "Copy
cannot create desire for a product. It
can only take the hopes, dreams, fears,
and desires that already exist in the
hearts of millions of people and focus
those already existing desires onto a
particular product. This is the
copywriter's task, not to create this
mass desire, but to channel and direct
it. The translation that Eugene Schwartz
is trying to teach in this is that you
shouldn't try to sell something you want
to sell. Sell something people want to
buy. Something they are already buying.
Something they have a current cultural
desire to invest in because your biggest
lever in selling isn't more ads, more
marketing. It's tapping into more desire
of what they already want. That one
thing alone may make you rich.